OPPORTUNITY TO GAIN A LITTLE
IT TO THE MIDDLE.
IT'S BEHIND
HE WAS EVEN THE OTHER NIGHT SCH.
OUT HIGH AND THE SHOT, HE
SCORES.
HE'S A MASSIVE BODY, PROVIDES SD
THAT LINE IN THE THIRD SHOT BY B
CHYCHRUN.
IT'S SHOWN UP IN ERIKSSON
PICKING UP THE A A TONINATO, EX.
>> Tyson: YOUR, TO THE BLOCK
OUT HIGH AND IT WAS FLIPPED COV.
>> Matt: HE CARRIES IT THROUGH
,
HE WALKED RIGHT IN ON THAT ONE.
>> Matt: CONNOR WILL DUMP GOAL.
THE GOALTENDER IS PLAYING GOOD
BUT YOU CAN'T HANG HIM OUT TOCKE
FRONT.
THE NET.
HE'S GOING TO LOOK TO
MOVE IT OUT.
COYOTES, HERE THEY COME.NOW.
>> Tyson: FOUR-ON-FOUR ACTION
HERE.
>> Matt: KELLER ACROSOS BEHIND T
COULDN'T HAND TELL, AND BACK
COMES WHEELER THE OTHER WAY.ND N
INTO THE BUTTERFLY, AND HE
THROWS IT RIGHT BELOW THEGALCHEA
STOP, COMRIE
THE RIGHT TOE OF COMRIE, AND
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THEY COME BACK
DODO
THIS IS THE FIRST PENALTY SHOT
IN THE CAREER OF SCOTT
T AND COMES UP LARGE.
LOOK AT THE OUT-SHOOTING THE
WINNIPEG JETS 27-M
BEHIND THE NET.
THE
STRALMAN.S THERE BY COMRIE.
>> Matt: A BIT OF